Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
um zwei stunden wandern wieder oder soll man besser sagen spazieren gehen eigentlich wandern
ich meine wir sind wieder knapp 300 höhenmeter gestälzt ja das ist immer echt entspannend ich
sag es euch leute ich hätte früher früher jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft ich hätte früher mich
selbst also ich hätte mir selbst nicht geglaubt früher haben ja auch die leute immer gesagt
max sitzt nicht den ganzen tag vom rechner ist schlecht habe ich das alter piss dich gehen wir
nicht auf den sack also ich hätte mir nicht selbst selbst nicht geglaubt aber es ist einfach
so es ist einfach so wenn man gerade wie ich und wahrscheinlich viele von euch den ganzen
tag vom rechner sitzt sowohl privat als auch auf der arbeit ich meine bei mir ist es ja im
prinzip triple oder quadruple schlimm ich sitze vom rechner auf der arbeit mit oder ohne home
office dann sitze ich privat vom rechner weil ich irgendwelche dinger mache ja von von youtube
gucken bis paar bis sachen ausprobieren spielen sachen programmieren was mich interessiert und
dann noch twitch livestream und dann noch youtube also bei mir ist es ja quadruple kacke und es
ist einfach wirklich für die gesamtgesundheit wirklich gut wenn man einfach am tag 1 2 mehr
muss das eigentlich sein stunden sich ein bisschen bewegt ich meine natürlich umso mehr so lange
sich total übertreibt umso besser aber das reicht schon ich meine was ich ich hatte ich hatte
übelste probleme hat der rücken immer weh getan ja ich hatte teilweise irgendwie verspannung die
irgendwie zwei wochen gebraucht haben bis es weggegangen ist oder sowas und als ich dann
irgendwann mal gesagt hat max kann doch nicht sein ich meine du bist zwar alter boomer mittlerweile
aber so alt bist du auch noch nicht und ich angefangen hat mich ein bisschen zu bewegen
gehst du stellse kommt hoff an teils teils und seitdem ist es wirklich es ist alles besser es
ist alles besser ja ja ich glaube wenn du liegen würdest oder permanent stehen wäre das jetzt auch
nicht der wahnsinn aber bestimmt besser als jetzt ja also das ist echt der wahnsinn
exquisite so also was haben wir denn schmuck wahrscheinlich heißt es schmuck oder schmuck
schmuck sagt moin max informiere mich derzeit über die physioausbildung lese leider öfters
dass das auch nach der ausbildung offenen job ist bei dem man quasi ein arsch vom dienst
es kommt darauf an wo du hingehst oder was du machst also es gibt ja wohl kaum was was so
vielfältig ist wie das was du als fachinformatiker nach der ausbildung machst wenn du natürlich
nichts kannst außer druckerpatronen wechseln oder irgendwie mäuse tauschen ja dann wirst du
wahrscheinlich dann auch so was machen müssen bei dem man quasi der arsch und also das kann
schon vorkommen aber das ist so vielfältig und es wird vor allem auch es wird vor allem auch
gesucht ja also du hast da schon die chancen saut mal ein bisschen leiser machen weil ich
soll ich das nicht und nicht in einer schleife laufen lassen und
ich brauche irgendwie irgendwie eine andere musik
mein das doch ein deutscher channel warum ist der titel auf englisch
doch auf deutsch lull was auch immer was war man denn hier zack
musik stellts taucht das happy kirby musik beste
so wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben also und immer nur irgendwelche to head probleme
der anderen angestellt löst das bei unternehmen tatsächlich das wie gesagt also wie gesagt es
kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an wo du hinkommst und vor allem halt auch was du kannst wenn nur
druckerpatronen und mäuse tauschen kannst dann ist das natürlich nicht wie soll ich sagen nicht
gerade förderlich dafür aber es gibt glaube ich keinen beruf der so vielfältig ist als das was
du am ende machst als wenn du fachinformatik gelernt hast gut ich meine aber stimmt was mit
dem sort nicht ist alles richtig weil das wird wahrscheinlich jeder irgendwie sagen zu seinem
beruf aber beim fachinformatik ist auf jeden fall so es kommt drauf an also weiß ich hast du
irgendwelche speziellen themen die dich interessieren da kann ich dir bloß empfehlen dass du dich weiter
damit auseinandersetzt weil es ist so kreislauf der dann entsteht wenn man wenn man sich für ein
gewisses gebiet interessiert dann lernt man das natürlich auch schneller und einfacher weil man
halt auch lieber zeit rein steckt und umso besser man in dem gebiet ist umso höher sind die chancen
dass man später auch in diesem gebiet arbeiten kann weil mal ehrlich so 0815 leute die bisschen
bist du bisschen windows hier irgendwelche windows settings und active directory zeug durchklicken
können das gibt es doch wie sand am mer kriegst du an jeder ecke leute die leute die druckerpatronen
tauschen kriegst du auch an jeder ecke leute die irgendwelche ach was weiß ich so ihr wisst was
ich meine ich muss jetzt nicht alles aufzählen so standardsachen kriegste kriegste an jeder ecke
aber was die was halt auch gesucht wird und wo es nicht so viele von gibt sind halt leute die sich
auskennen in einem in einem speziellen bereich sei es jetzt je nachdem was man hat amazon google
azure cloud geschichten irgendwelche was weiß ich software stacks von elastic search bis
monitoring mit von lockstash bis elastic search bis was weiß ich grafana gedöns um druff dann
anbindung ansonsten also was weiß ich es gibt so es gibt so viel sachen also da fällt mir jetzt
gar nicht alles ein auch im kleinsten cloud umfeld was kubernetes angeht was linux container angeht
ist so viel oder auch was virtualisierung angeht das ist so viel wo so viele three hat leute
rumlaufen und die alle hände ringen suchen nach leuten die was können und dementsprechend auch
was bezahlen müssten also es lohnt sich ja so jetzt haben wir das
so ich muss mal kurz hier gucken also was haben wir noch bewegung ist unheimlich wichtig ja
korrekt so ist es ist es arg schlimm wenn man kreislauf für was für stehen zu zu bed ist ja
da würde ich mir gedanken machen da würde ich mir gedanken als wenn es beim beim stehen schon
schwierig wird ich meine ich kenne das ja kann schon mal vorkommen aber muss er nicht übertreiben
so was gibt es denn hierfür antwort ich habe die selbe aus muss sagen dass es nicht mehr so ist wie
viele erzählen am besten um so in welcher genau also das ist e was das habe ich auch in einem der
letzten videos die region ist wichtig wo man ist also ich denke mal wenn jetzt irgendwie tief im
osten ist dann wird man in der regel immer weniger bekommen als wenn man jetzt sagen wir mal irgendwo
in frankfurt ist da gibt natürlich oder was weiß ich hamburg berlin wo auch immer es da viel gibt
wobei letztens habe ich ja mit mit niklas video aufgenommen hat gemacht in hamburg haben sie im
29 im jahr angeboten das war jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn region ist unglaublich wichtig und halt
auch im endeffekt dass man irgendwas kann ich meine wie gesagt druckerpatronen tauscher gibt
es wie sand am mer aber leute die was können und und in kombination auch halbwegs umgänglich
sind ich glaube das tatsächlich relativ selten wir haben auch leute was können die nicht umgänglich
sind es gibt so viel es gibt so unglaublich viel nervige leute abzuglück kann man den meistens
aus dem weg gehen das ist ein zweiter account ich habe nur die name erkannt
im third level lässt man patronen wechseln das aber komischer level also ich sitze ja bei uns in
der nähe von der hotline ich sitze also mehr oder weniger dabei ich arbeite nicht bei der hotline
aber ich sitze so dabei also nicht hotline für irgendwie hallo mein drucke ist kaputt
sondern wenn irgendwas wenn irgendwas überwachungstechnisch down ist ja also sprich
nicht nicht wirklich first level eher so was richtung wie nennt man das operate operation center
oder so was in der richtung da sitze ja dabei oder sind teilweise echt komische anrufe dabei
zum beispiel was was der klassiker schlechthin ist ja immer noch das kommt eigentlich fast jedes
mal vor der klassiker schlechthin ist ja auch irgendwas wichtiges geht nicht sagen wir irgendein
teil für den außendienst irgendein teilsystem ist ausgefallen und dann stehen dann leute vorne
und sagen ja aber in der testumgebung da müssen wir jetzt unbedingt was ausprobieren und keiner
hilft uns dabei dann sagen die leute ja aber guck mal hier ist es gerade was ganz wichtiges kaputt
so nach dem motto das kostet jetzt fünf millionen am tag wenn es kaputt ist übertrieben gesagt ja
aber mein test in der testumgebung wenn das da nicht funktioniert das sind die weiß auch nicht
die sind immer komplett komplett an der realität vorbei teilweise so ach ja stimmt warum hast du mir
das warum hast du mir das geschickt das stimmt ja das wollte ich euch das habe ich euch doch
erzählt das letzte mal schon ich habe ich habe den programmierer von dieser custom firma doch
drei thermostate gespendet dass sie anpassen können dass sie den display controller anpassen
können weil es gab ja eine neue version von den thermostaten oder display controller ging
nicht mehr und dem habe ich drei stück geschickt und daraufhin gab es vor zwei tagen support für
b16 und jetzt support für b19 das richtig würde ich sagen das heißt wir können die
dinge demnächst flaschen und wer die sich noch kaufen will ich habe kein ref link oder sowas
aber alles weiter ist als erstes davor ali express wenn du ali suchst mittlerweile passt
ja wieder gut zusammen so wenn man hier mal guckt nach die gibt es aktuell relativ günstig bei den
china chinesen im 10er pack im 10er pack für 2 euro 70 oder sowas kann das sein dass es das
nicht mehr gibt wo ist es hin wo ist denn hin gibt kein gibt kein 10er pack mehr da habe ich
aber noch mal glück gehabt dass ich den kram bestellt habe also man konnte die sich im 10er
pack kaufen vor ungefähr 2 euro 70 das stück das war nice ja das machen wir das machen wir
aber die nächsten tage dann wieder ich sehe es schon ich kann nur chat lesen und gehe ich
wieder offen zwei stunden ich muss ja morgen früh die arbeit fahren wenn die wenn die bahn kommt
leute die haben ich vor jetzt habe ich glaube ich schon erzählt aber die haben ich ja vor
zwei wochen oder so so extrem also sie regen mich ja jeden dienstag auf ihr kennt es ja ich bin ja
quasi jeden dienstag also ich bin pünktlicher als die bahn am flamen über die bahn auf twitter
aber vor zwei wochen oder so da haben sie mich echt so extrem aufgeregt ja guckst du guckst in
die app ich kann das bestimmt du guckst in die app und so lange nichts dasteht ist verdächtig weil
nichts dastehen bedeutet in der regel die bahn weiß selbst nicht wo dazu ist und wenn es pünktlich
da steht heißt es das kann auch nicht sein das hat noch keiner aktualisiert also am besten ist wenn
du in die bahn app guckst und der hat so plus zwei wenn er plus zwei hat dann weißt du es hat
jemand aktualisiert und erscheint halbwegs pünktlich zu sein so und vor zwei wochen stand in der bahn
ab ich sage plus sechs oder so also kaum verspätung das war wunderbar kein problem bin ich runter ihr
wisst ja ich wohne nicht weit vom bahnhof weg und was sind die vier erzfeine der der bahn das ist ja
alterwitz frühlings frühlings sommer herbst und winter die vier feine der deutschen bahn aber da
gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile schon etwas andere versionen von dem witz zumindest bin ich dann
rüber ans bahnkreis und dann waren die fünf minuten um und er kam nicht und auf einmal und
auf einmal wurde in der app angezeigt plus 35 minuten und dann habe ich mir nach scheiße was
das da habe ich übelst rumgeflucht am bahnhof das weiß ich noch und da stand halt in den typ
neben mir haben wir uns angeguckt so alter wollen die uns verarschen komme ich gleich noch drauf
zurück so zumindest dann geguckt nächster zug nächster zug nächster zug fällt aus
das heißt der einer hat auf einmal instant 35 minuten verspätung gekriegt als wusste man das
vorher nicht der nächste fällt aus und der nächste da drauf der ist noch gar nicht losgefahren vermute
ich mal der hatte auch schon irgendwie 35 45 minuten da weißte was könnte mich mal ich gehe
jetzt wieder heim ja und um auf den typ zurückzukommen wo ich da ein bisschen rumgeflucht
hat am bahnhof letzte woche kollege bei mir auf der arbeit meint so ja du hast auch letztes
ganz schön rumgemeckert am bahnhof hab ich gesagt hä woher weißt du das er meinte sie haben einen
sohn hat man die haben bahnhof mitgestanden das war wohl sein sohn wo ich darum geflammt hab ja
kommt vorher so ok jetzt ich wusste wenn ich mit dem chat nicht hinterher kommen wird das halt
überhaupt nicht warum ich der sohn kennt der sohn kennt mich das ist tatsächlich ganz lustig die
chancen sind nicht hoch dass mich der sohn kennt aber der sohn kennt mich aus dem grund weil der
mit seinem vater mal eine woche oder tag ich weiß es gar nicht mehr es gibt ja so einen keine ahnung
besucht deinen vater bei der arbeit oder so was oder vielleicht war das auch in den praktikum
von der schule oder ich weiß nicht der war zumindest bei uns bei uns in frankfurt auf der
arbeit deswegen kennt er mich so was was haben bei euch an der arbeit welche den beruf bachelor
gemacht operator profession das sind diese fortbildungs dinger von der ihk ne boah keine
ahnung meine mein persönliches gefühl dazu ist aber nehmt es jetzt mal mit so gehörig portion
skeptis dass sich kein mensch dafür interessiert für die komischen ihk fortbildung ich habe
glaube ich noch nie ein so in the wild gesehen der die ihk die ihk fortbildung hatte aber
leute könnt mich also wenn ihr irgendwie einen kennt oder selbst das gemacht hat dann schreibt
ruhig den chat ich habe keinen plan also ich kenne niemand was macht man wenn man sich für
mehrere bereiche interessiert gut dann muss ja etwas aussuchen oder es sind bereiche die man
gut miteinander verbinden kann ja zum beispiel wenn du dich jetzt machen wir das mal an mir fest
ja also wenn du dich viel für automatisierung und linux sachen interessiert plus fürs programmieren
dann ist natürlich was richtung der fobs oder richtung cloud engineering oder irgendwas in der
richtung natürlich was sinnvolles man muss ja nicht nur eine sich auf eine sache festlegen es
gibt auch viele bereiche die sich ganz gut ergänzen und wenn du dich für mehrere bereiche
interessiert muss man mal gucken man das nicht irgendwie gut miteinander kombinieren kann
gut z plus plus ist eh vorbei das ist also z wenn es wirklich leute gibt die gerne z plus plus
machen da will ich mit dem nichts zu tun haben ich habe ein problem mein headset hat aussetze
auf der einen seite was ist denn das hier so jetzt ich hoffe es ist besser hier einfach klar
gibt warum gibt es leute den z plus plus gefällt ich verstehe es nicht ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen
but why netzwerktechnik sind sehr gesucht ja das ist das ist wirklich so ja ja gut cc na ist im
prinzip z sogar ich habe einen cc na das sagt alles und ich habe nicht großartige ahnung was
netzwerktechnik angeht ja ist bei uns auch so die sind auch hart am suchen was was netzwerksachen
angeht wir haben das ja mittlerweile bei uns ist ja so die haben das ja halt so halb out gesourced
was netzwerktechnik angeht im prinzip haben die das richtig big brain gemacht ja bei uns haben
sofort zwei drei jahren sind sie auf die idee gekommen so dass wir jetzt alles aussourcen
alles aussourcen und daraufhin haben sie einfach die leute die früher bei uns die netzwerktechnik
gemacht haben sind dann quasi geschlossen haben ich weiß nicht ob die die firma gegründet haben
oder geschlossen zu irgendeiner anderen firma gegangen sind die das dann an uns wieder verkauft
ist eigentlich richtig richtig big brain aktion gewesen spontane nicht streben ja und dann teurer
da kannst du gift drauf nehmen dass das teurer ist gut es hat natürlich andere vorteile dann
muss ich sagen das habe ich auch lange zeit immer nicht verstanden es hat oftmals seine
ford also es kostet geld dass man im ernstfall die schuld auf jemand anderen schieben kann das
ist ja das ist ja der sinn von dieser ganzen geschichte ja sei es jetzt auch irgendwelche
acl oder sonst was es geht im nehmt nicht acl clas nicht als die ganze drei drei buchstaben
abkürzung das ist ja im prinzip dazu da nicht wirklich dass die sachen weniger kaputt gehen
sla sla meine ich meine güte ja dings service was ist service level agreement ja abkürzung
kann es schon mal durcheinander kommen zumindest ist es ja ist es ja im prinzip so es geht durch
den sla geht ja auch nicht weniger kaputt aber du kannst die schuld auf jemand anderes schieben
und das kostet halt einfach geld deswegen ist das auch eigentlich alles immer teurer
warum wollen eigentlich alle informatik und elektrotechnik weiß ist das so ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass es einfach für sag mal informatik und dieses das ganze ökosystem drum
herum dass das vielleicht ein bisschen größer ist und mehr gebraucht wird als elektrotechnik
das weiß ich aber nicht ich meine du brauchst mit sicherheit elektrotechniker aber ich weiß
nicht ob du die in der menge brauchst ich habe keine ahnung und ich weiß auch gar nicht ob
das wirklich so ist es gab am wochenende stream sonntag morgens viereinhalb stunden oder so
also ja bin noch generell unschlüssig nehmen moment kann ich lesen ja bin mir generell
noch ein wenig unschlüssig zwischen systemetik hast auch gar nicht angefangen ja dann würde
ich mir gar keine gedanken machen weil irgendjemand sagt du bist adept vom dienst dann fangen
erst mal an ich dachte du bist jetzt dabei und bist du bei einer firma gelandet wo das
nicht so dolle ist ne ne ne ne dann dann würde ich mir da wirklich keine um diese ungelegten
eier nur wirklich keine gedanken machen ein wenig unschlüssig zwischen systemetik
also wobei ich weiß systemetik hat so gut für dass man jedenfalls auch mal was zusammenbaut
oder so server oder was weiß ich naja selten heute nee ich finde also hardware generell
schon interessant vom bereiche finde ich eigentlich die autos ja also ob man nicht so viele server
zusammenbaut halte ich fraglich ich glaube ich habe in meiner ausbildung nie server zusammengebaut
und ist auch schon ein bisschen her und heute wird man das noch weniger machen was wir natürlich
gemacht haben ist die sachen getauscht aber die es ist aber so server sind ja in der regel
so gebaut dass du die relativ modular austauschen kannst ja von mehrere netzteilen bis netzwerkkarten
und sonst was die sind eigentlich schon fix und fertig du musst halt ab und zu mal was
tauschen turnschuhe admins genau ja das ist tatsächlich in der ausbildung gar nicht schlecht
da lernt man wirklich da lernt man wirklich viel wenn man mit den kisten an sich was machen
muss ich weiß muss ich überlegen das bei mir war das ja 2007 das ist mittlerweile natürlich
auch alles ein bisschen anders aber ich bin noch ins rechenzentrum rübergegangen in der
ausbildung und musste eine red hat dvd einlegen und vollinstallation machen weil und jetzt
kommt jetzt kommt boomer erzählt euch vom griech ja aber weil bei uns damals die datenbank
leute der meinung waren sie brauchen eine red hat vollinstallation frage ich habe bis
heute keine ahnung warum man auch für eine eine oracle datenbank eine rett hat vollinstallation
brauche aber die wollten eine rett hat vollinstallation haben und vollinstallation heißt auch wenn
du dann monitor angeschlossen hast ist ein klom gestartet ich keine ahnung warum ja und
zur autoindustrie kann ich nichts sagen keine ahnung warum nicht ja das kann man sich auch
fragen höhenverstellbarer schreibt ich ja höhenverstellbarer schreibt ich jetzt richtig
pock ich habe hier auch ein ich habe aber gerade meinen schaltern wo habe ich meinen
schalter denn dafür hin ich habe hier so ein berg aus aus briefen und papierkram das
bestimmt irgendwo hier unten unter egal ja ich habe auch einen höhenverstellbaren schreibt
ich und das ist wirklich pock aus man muss sich aber aber eins sagen kann ich empfehlen
es ist gut sich irgendwo ran zu merken was so die default höhe ist sei es dass man das
so eingestellt dass die armlehne gerade noch drunter passt oder dass man neben irgendwas
drunter legt oder so weil es ist nervig die perfekte position wieder zu finden nachdem
er ihn hochgefahren hat man gewöhnt sich ja schnell dran naja das allein wird es nicht
sein aber du hast schon mal mit zwei wirklich interessanten technologien gearbeitet und
hier auch was man also da hast du sicherlich was beigelernt was dazu beitragen kann dass
das du später mal begehrt bist mit rein von graf hana dashboards zusammenklicken ist jetzt
vielleicht weil es vielleicht doofes beispiel da es juckt jetzt auch nicht großartig macht
es noch sinn hardcore programmierer zu werden was du für pornhub oder achso hier wird nach
indien polen gibt es auch zu können ne ne quatsch da hab ich meine zweifel da hab ich wirklich
meine zweifel ob das wirklich so ist dass eis das mal programmieren ich mein github
wie hieß der kram github code assist ne wie hieß der kram nochmal github code pilot code
pilot ja genau ist nur wirklich nicht das womit du was generierst was du danach auch
benutzen kannst das ist ja und selbst und selbst wenn du damit die assisten lässt ist
das teilweise fragwürdig das ist eher ganz ehrlich benutzt jemand regelmäßig github
github code pilot ich hab bisher nur github copilot memes gesehen also gut der memes generator
ist das ob das jetzt wirklich praktische relevanz hat weiß ich nicht so wirklich ich hab
kein herrmann miller stuhl ich hab ein sedus mister 24 was das ist github code pilot die
haben bei microsoft also github gehört ja microsoft die haben quasi die komplette github
code base von der ai wie nennt man das analysieren lassen und generieren die jetzt quasi on
the fly passend zu deinem programm code vorschläge wie du weiter programmieren könntest also
ja ich hab da mein so und das wird das wird in nächster zeit nicht eintreten dass jetzt
irgendwelche ai sich selbst sich selbst programmieren kann das glaube ich nicht es wird sicherlich
in die in die richtung gehen nicht dass quasi komplett neue projekte ai mäßig erstellt
werden oder sowas aber was ich mir vorstellen könnte ist dass algorithmen irgendwie andere
algorithmen wieder optimieren und laufzeit optimieren und sowas in der richtung vielleicht
ja aber dass du dass du jetzt quasi eine ai sagst ich brauche bleiben wir mal bei was
ganz praktisch relevantem ja ich brauche eine software die mir bilder als overlay anzeigen
kann und die programmiert dann da irgendwas was ich haben will am ende glaube da sind
wir noch deutlich weiter als zehn jahre voll entfernt ja ja und das ist halt die sind und
die sind ich mein ich weiß dass du nicht dass du das was ich am anfang gesagt nicht nur
hardcore programmierer versteht aber seit die sache was was verstehst du darunter es
geht es also es geht wie es geht eindeutig weg davon dass man den ganzen tag vom rechner
sitzt und irgendwas am hack am hacker man ist und nicht nach links und rechts guckt
aber da muss man mal ehrlich sein das ist auch das ist auch in letzter zeit schon nicht
mehr so gewesen oder schon eine ganze weile nicht so ja und umso mehr leute daran beteiligt
sind umso mehr musst du dich halt auch um sachen drumherum kümmern sei es um irgendwelche
ticketverwaltung irgendwelche bugtracker irgendwelche daily geschichten oder was auch
immer das ist man kann sich darüber streiten also ich finde dass das teilweise ich mein
ich bin kein hauptberuflicher programmierer aber ist bei mir auch schon teilweise heftig
wenn du dir anguckst wie wenig vom tag man wirklich was sinnvolles macht das beste das
beste beispiel bei mir ist immer ich bin ja ich gehe morgen ich fahre morgen wieder
auf die arbeit ich mache ich mache mit geteilt homeoffice und vorort morgen fahre ich wieder
vorort und ich ich habe ich habe das überhaupt nicht so mitbekommen zu der zeit vor corona
wo man da jeden tag hingefallen ist aber wie ineffektiv und wenig man eigentlich vorort
macht das ist echter wahnsinn du kommst dann morgens rein dann hörst du dann dann erzählt
dir erst einmal 20 min ja mags hier lang nicht da gewesen sonst war es irgendwie so hier
bla und da und hast dir die upload zweimal weiter gespielt und sonst was ok dann bist
erst mal bis erst mal ein bisschen am schwätzen danach nehme ich meistens zettel guck mal
rüber wer im büro noch so da ist meistens keiner da wenn einer da ist kriegst du noch
mal zum anspielen was erzählt so da gehe ich wieder rüber setze mich hin und dann wird
meistens gemietet dann ist dann also morgen morgen ist schon mal drei meetings in folge
das weiß ich jetzt schon und dazwischen wenn du dann vorort bist ist auch noch meistens
irgendwas wo dann einer neben dir am tisch steht irgendwas will oder du willst jemanden
nur kurz mal was fragen so nach dem motto hier hast du dir das und das ticket schon
mal angeguckt dann erzählt er noch irgendwie ach ja wie sieht es denn damit aus habt ihr
euch darum schon gekümmert also es ist unglaublich wie ineffektiv eigentlich so der tägliche
arbeitsablauf ist das ist mir früher gar nicht eingeleuchtet das also das ist das ganz
extrem also morgen weiß ich jetzt schon wieder da werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht so nicht
allzu viel kommen wobei ich morgen unbedingt was machen muss es ist wichtig morgen ist
ein kollege von mir wieder am start und wir gucken uns da so ein paar sachen ab und zu
mal zusammen an da müssen wir unbedingt was fertig machen naja egal tja und der trend
geht ja tatsächlich schon eher ein bisschen wieder in die andere richtung dass das out
gesorgen wieder eingesorgen wird was softwareentwicklung angeht ja ich finde es aber auch nicht verkehrt
dass man in der ausbildung wenn man die chance hat schon ein bisschen was lernen weil man
ganz im ernst ganz ganz ehrlich in der ausbildung ist es im prinzip vollkommen egal ob du jetzt
also wenn du scheiße baust interessiert das kein danach ist das halt nicht mehr so das
heißt in der ausbildung ist es wirklich gut vielleicht auch mal die ein oder anderen
sachen auszuprobieren wurde ich später nicht mal so richtig draus wenn du das unbedingt
machen willst nee aber in der ausbildung hast du halt die chance wirklich wie soll
ich denn gefahrlos dich mal so ein bisschen an sachen ran zu tasten ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern also ich habe in der ausbildung nie was kaputt gemacht es gab aber mal eine
sache die haben sie haben sie uns angelastet da war ich im phoenix drüben im rechenzentrum
phoenix kennt ihr glaube ich kennt ihr auch von den gamescom videos noch der ein oder
andere da haben sie uns damals gesagt wir sollen einen alten esx ausbauen glaube ich
war das lustigerweise mein jetziger chef hat das hat mir das damals als auftrag gegeben
als er in der ausbildung war also wir sollen rüber gehen irgendwie esx entkabeln oder
so im rechenzentrum ihr könnt euch vorstellen also unser rechenzentrum die wand sah ungefähr
so aus wo die kabel waren das viel zu ordentlich was hier ja so in der richtung aber das trifft
es immer auch noch nicht warum ist das alles so ordentlich nee nee nee ja so so eher in
diese richtung sah unsere unsere switch wand aus mit mit den ganzen panels drauf nur dass
es hier noch noch voller war also du hast bei uns im rechenzentrum früher hast du hier
so viele kabel davor dass du die geräte drunter nicht mal gesehen hast such vorhangsverkabelung
was ja so naja gut ganz ganz so extrem mit also ja doch dass das das das hier spiegelt
die realität relativ gut wieder so haben sie uns damals rüber geschickt felix und mich
haben gesagt hier könnte das sowas hier ja ja doch so ungefähr sah das aus könne das
könne das ausbauen haben wir gemacht wir haben abgestöpselt und auf einmal kommt einer rüber
gerannt und und voll voller panik so irgendwie ja netzwerk ist da und irgendwie sonst was
ja und anscheinend waren halt andere kabel nicht richtig gesteckt nicht richtig gesteckt
und es hat gewackelt beim ausbauen wir haben nicht das falsche kabel gezogen aber ich
weiß noch damals wollten sie uns das anlasten die haben gesagt die azubis waren im rechenzentrum
und haben das falsche kabel gezogen das stimmt überhaupt nicht wir haben nicht das falsche
kabel gezogen wir haben nur die richtigen kabel gezogen und irgendein anderes kabel
was da wahrscheinlich auch nicht richtig drinne war hat halt wahrscheinlich gewackelt und
da haben sie uns das versucht damals anzulasten so nach dem ah ja gut muss man sich nicht
so aufregend die Azubis waren dabei waren die es überhaupt nicht aber ansonsten habe
ich nie was kaputt gemacht in der ausbildung wie häufig gibt es ein layer 8 error also
ich würde sagen 95 prozent der probleme liegen entweder an unfähigen anwendern oder an unfähigen
administratoren der rest zum größten teil an unfähigen programmierern aber bei so standard
software eher weniger das was da ankommt ist ja meistens schon ganz gut erprobt ja
und ein prozent ist dann wahrscheinlich wirklich mal was aber 95 prozent sind unfähige anwender
und fähige admins wird bei euch auch wieder eine weihnachtsfeier geplant bei uns gibt
es wurde digital das ist eine gute frage keine ahnung interessiert mich aber auch nicht weil
ich bin ende des jahres eh nicht mehr da also ich habe nicht gekündigt oder so aber ich
bin ja immer ende des jahres bis nächstes jahr dann nicht da kriegst du die geräte
wieder zurück nö habe ich ihm gesagt kann er behalten der 2 euro 70 pro gerät wen juckts
ein open source entwickler der schnell patcht ja also eins muss man immer wirklich sagen
die waren sau schnell ich habe ihm das vor einer woche geschickt und er hat das sofort
hier reverse engineered neues display neue display adressen eingetragen und sonst was
also das ist wirklich richtig richtig big brain ist ja nicht so als hätte ich er als
hätte ich irgendwie gedrängelt oder so gut ich meine der patch naja hier so wenig ist
das nett was er machen musste fürs neue display ah ob wir es das hätte ich auch das hätte
ich ihm auch gleich sagen können dass er das reinschreiben muss also chat wer das nicht
versteht dann weiß ich auch nicht also ich finde dass ich das wie sagt man schon klar
wie close brühe ja was hier passiert vor allem dass es da noch hier 16 bits nach rechts
geschifft und minus 450 obv obviously ganz klar ganz klar aber muss man echt sagen also
er war sehr zackig und natürlich kann er die geräte behalten ich habe ihm drei stück
geschickt zwei original verpackte und eins was ich schon aufgeschraubt hatte ich habe
ja auch dabei geschrieben ja dauert halt so lange wie es dauert ach hier guck mal ist
das das ja genau hier sind zehn stück zehn stück für aus china teurer geworden das
ist teurer geworden das letzte mal hat es nur noch als nur 27 euro gekostet könnt ihr
nachgucken ist das ein deutscher ja oder niederländer aber ich glaube deutscher
das ist was anderes das letzte mal war noch zehn tage ja das ist jetzt ein anderes angebot
das letzte mal war noch lieferbar innerhalb von zehn tagen und es hat noch 27 euro gekostet
da hätte ich mir das mal angeguckt hätte ich gar nicht auseinanderschrauben müssen
natürlich ja kann seine kinder glücklich machen mit geräten von aliexpress aber auch
im ernst 30 euro ist auch ok wobei das letzte mal war glaube ich nicht kostenfreier versand
aber bis 15 november gut 15 november sind auch nur drei wochen also preislich ist auf
jeden fall gut hast du ungefähr 3 euro 10 pro stück bei amazon de kostet 8 euro übrigens
habt ihr auch gelesen dass die chinesische wirtschaft wohl so ein bisschen probleme hat
oder bekommt gerade wo kriege ich denn dann mein ganzes china chinesen zeuschen wenn die
jetzt alle den bach runtergehen wobei vielleicht ist es ja auch vielleicht ist es ja auch für
uns ganz gut wenn es den chinesen nicht so gut geht weil dann sind die sachen weiterhin
billig aber letztendlich hauptsache hauptsache ich krieg mein günstiges zeug von aliexpress
da rest es mir egal warum will man so was smiley drauf näher das smiley ist der ist eigentlich
nur bonus du siehst die luftfeuchtigkeit und die temperatur und das ganze kannst du wireless
per bluetooth slow also ble low bluetooth low energie was was heißt ble genau bluetooth
low energie doch genau stromsparen übertragen deswegen brauche man dafür auch die custom
firmware die original firmware überträgt das nehme ich alle fünf sekunden und dann
ist die batterie nach einem halben jahr leer wenn du deine custom firmware drauf machst
da kannst du einstellen dass du das nur nach fünf minuten übertragen oder 15 minuten oder
sonst was nach fünf minuten ist ok und ich habe das jetzt ein jahr drüben und die batterie
ist bei 75 oder 78 prozent oder so glaube ich moin sturmklötze also custom firma lohnt
sich da schon auf jeden fall ja leider leider also es ist nicht mehr das gleiche angebot
aber es ist immer noch es ist immer noch günstig wie ist deine meinung zu thema home office
zu jünger zittrigs mit eigenen geräten oder vpn zum beispiel das ist das ist ein pence
champ thema bei uns leute ja ich ich eigentlich auch ich habe mir vor einer weile notebook
bestellt den haben sie bis heute nicht geliefert ich habe da sogar mal gefragt wie es denn
aussieht und da haben sie bloß gesagt ja wir melden uns dann wenn er da ist ok was
soll ich machen aber ansonsten das ist ziemlich pence champ pence champiges thema bei uns
was notebooks und so angeht mir persönlich wäre es am liebsten man könnte sich einfach
per vpn verbinden und gut ist man könnte ja noch wenn man zugang zu wichtigen system
braucht noch mal irgendwie noch zu mal noch mal zusätzliche zwei faktor authentifierung
noch mal also noch mal ein zweiter zwei faktor authentifizierung davor machen wenn man das
haben will ja das würde ich das verstehe ich oder dass man auf eine gesicherte auf
eine gesicherte vm muss wenn man eben zugang zu produktivsystem haben will also das wird
das würde ich alles verstehen aber zum normalen zugang wäre ich ja persönlich für vpn und
dann hat einfach vpn den ich mir selbst installieren kann kriegst ein zertifikat oder meinetwegen
kriegst pre-shared key muss ich einloggen danach dich alternifizieren noch mal zertifikat
einrichten was auch immer ja also ich persönlich bin fan von vpn und vpn was einfach funktioniert
und package installiert unter linux und gut ist
gibt aber viele möglichkeiten
ja wireguard ist im businessbereich nicht so beliebt also im businessbereich ist es
meistens das was hier steht nicht check ist es entweder checkpoint also checkpoint hab
ich schon gesehen oder
40 klein gibt es zum beispiel aus dem businessbereich auch relativ beliebt oder halt die cisco ipsec
implementierung also
im businessbereich ist wireguard tatsächlich nicht so verbreitet
cisco anyconnect genau ja den meine ich ja ja also ich glaube 40 klein ist relativ beliebt
wie gesagt anyconnect auch hallo alto networks ja keine ahnung aber so diese dinge also
wireguard sieht man da in the wild jetzt relativ selten vielleicht bei irgendwelchen start ups
oder so das ticket buchen ist nicht das problem dass das sucht dann kommt ist das problem
wie gesagt frühlingssummer herbst und winter
ab fünf minuten ist glaube ich verspätung bei der bahn aber das juckt eh alles aktuell
nicht also morgen könnt ihr euch schon wieder darauf verlassen werde ich auf twitter die
bahn flamen weil ich mir jetzt schon sicher bin dass der scheiß nicht pünktlich ist und
die haben es wirklich geschafft ich bin jetzt sieben mal oder so gefahren und die waren nie
pünktlich nie das musst du erst mal schaffen das ist so schlecht es ist unbenutzbar schlecht
es ist nicht einfach nur schlecht es ist quasi komplett ohne existenzberechtigung zur zeit also
echt lächerlich da kannst du doch keinem übel nehmen das sagt er will noch ein auto haben oder
will auto fahren oder sonst was natürlich muss es natürlich muss es die bahn geschissen kriegen
aber wir diskutieren ja schon wieder komplett in die falsche richtung ja es wird darüber
diskutiert soll man nicht autos in den innenstädten verbieten oder hier und da nein man sollte erst
mal gucken dass die leute noch die möglichkeit haben von a nach b zu kommen und dann verzichten
viele garantiert freiwillig drauf mit dem auto zu fahren kann so nicht den zweiten schritt
vor dem ersten schritt machen die sollen das funktionieren das ist auch wieder so absolut
nicht nachgedacht ja das kommt auch öfters mal zu kommt auch mal so dass kein sucht kommt ich
ich habe das in letzter zeit gemerkt mein also mein hirn wird wirklich älter ne ich mach oft
mal schweiß ich zwei wörter zusammen weil ich den satz noch am aussprechen bin aber in meinem
kopf schon weiterdenke an das danach und dann mache ich dann so komische kombinationen wie eben
hat jemand bei euch den doktor wir haben nein wir haben keinen mit doktor mehr wir hatten
mal einen mit doktor und ich kann euch aus eigener erfahrung sagen ich habe relativ mit
dem viel mit ihm zusammenarbeiten müssen das war das ist aber ein spezieller mensch glaube
nicht dass es am doktor liegt ja das war schon sehr speziell und pains jam mit ihm zusammen zu
arbeiten irgendwann haben wir das dann so gemacht wir hatten immer wir hatten immer gemiete mit
ihm mit drei verschiedenen leuten und wir haben uns bevor wir mit ihm gemietet haben schon immer
abgesprochen was wir sagen dass es eben einheitlich klingt und die meetings waren immer nach fünf
minuten fertig weil wir immer alle die klein einstimmig die gleichen antworten gegeben haben
da war er zufrieden dabei haben wir dabei hat es nicht wirklich der realität entsprochen sondern
wir haben uns einfach im vorfeld überlegt was wir jetzt sagen aber es ist eher erstaunlich es
ist eher erstaunlich wie selten die realität so im business stonks enterprise umfeld überhaupt
interessiert die realität ist meistens gar nicht das was gefragt ist ob es auch die leute haben
irgendwie ein gutes gefühl dabei ob das jetzt der realität entspricht und nicht ist eigentlich
meistens wurscht und im zweifelsfall vergessen er die leute dies entscheiden müssen wieder dass
sie mal was entschieden haben was zu problemen geführt hat das hat man das haben wir uns auch
öfters so nach dem motto du sagst ja aber wenn wir das jetzt nicht nehmen wir mal ein beispiel ja
wenn wir das jetzt nicht ordentlich aufschreiben wird irgendwas ausdenken keine ahnung wenn wir
jetzt nicht ordentlich aufschreiben auf welchen ports irgendwelche services laufen dann finden
wir das nachher nicht mehr und dann gibt es dann leute die sagen das ist ein aushängeschildprojekt
das kann jetzt nicht auf so was warten da muss man halt dabei sagen ja gut aber das wird garantiert
zu problemen führen wenn man das nicht aufschreibt weil wenn mal was kaputt ist dann brauchen wir
bestimmt doppelt so lang rauszufinden wo was läuft das ist egal aushängeschildprojekt das
machen wir jetzt und wir nehmen dann wird dann dazu noch gesagt wir nehmen auch noch das mit
den ports bei zum beispiel wir nehmen dann auch in kauf dass es dann etwas länger dauert so da
geht es kaputt es dauert ein bisschen länger und danach kommt dann was wie kann das sein dass die
IT dafür so lange braucht wissen die nicht was sie machen was macht denn die IT wieder warum
kennen die ihre eigenen selbst nicht das ist eigentlich immer der gleiche kram man vergisst
das dann immer so selektiv so was wie das habe ich gesagt der kann überhaupt nicht sein deswegen
was unglaublich gut ist deswegen habe ich ja auch so meine liste was das angeht habe ich ja auch
meine video gesagt immer wenn man irgendwelche entscheidungen hört oder sachen hört von dem
man denkt oh das könnte noch nach hinten losgehen und wir haben damit was zu tun schreibe ich mir
das mittlerweile auf zumindest so grob da steht dann zum beispiel sowas wie drin keine ahnung
ende oktober wurde erzählt bis ende des jahres muss dienst xy abgeschaltet sein oder sowas und
dann mal gucken was dann dabei rauskommt weil es kann durchaus sein dass sich dann irgendeiner
wieder drüber beschwert und man dann nicht mehr weiß was was man damals entschieden hat
mut zur lücke ich habe damit kein problem ich finde das vollkommen in ordnung dass man sagt
hey das ist jetzt so sowas wegweisen dass das wurde schon zum beispiel ich habe überhaupt kein
problem damit wenn man sagt hey man hat jetzt beispielsweise unseren ganzen außendienstleuten
hat man versprochen dass es bis ende des jahres produkt xy gibt und wenn man dann sagt hey wir
wissen dass wir nicht alle details genau erledigen können bis ende des jahres und wir nehmen dann
halt in kauf dass xy z als fehler auftreten können da habe ich überhaupt kein problem damit das ist
ja so wie sagt man so eine business entscheidung das zu machen habe ich auch als techniker wenig
schmerzen mit wo ich probleme damit habe ist wenn man dann darauf hinweist so nach dem motto okay
das bedeutet aber auch in dem und dem fall gibt es da probleme und dann sagt man ja das ist uns
bewusst aber das können wir jetzt nicht machen weil das ist keine zeit für habe ich überhaupt
keine produktion ok business entscheidung alles in ordnung wenn es dann aber kaputt geht und man
dann sich nicht mehr daran erinnern will dass man das gesagt hat das ist das was mir auf den keks
geht der andere fall ist vollkommen egal es ist mir vollkommen egal weil ich muss das nicht
entscheiden ich muss das nicht außen hin vertreten und ich muss auch nicht mein kopf
für ihn halten wenn irgendwas kap wenn irgendwas ist ja also mir ist das egal wenn man sich dafür
entscheidet aber dann soll man sich wenigstens daran erinnern wenn was ist deswegen schreibe
ich mir solche sachen meistens auf mittlerweile wenn ich denke das könnte mal wichtig werden
du bist fertig mit ausbildungen als gg jetzt machst du mit machst du im winter abschlussprüfung
im discord hat sich wer von echt nice das muss ich mir mal angucken du könntest mich mal im
mod im mod channel das verknüpfen oder so fast falls ich über sehen habe das ist das ist cool
auch jemand von der ihk interviewen das wird ja was alter da muss ich mich da muss ich mich
ein bisschen entspannen weil ich flay mir ja ganz gerne mal die ihk das ist so wie wenn ich
jemand von der bahn interviewen müsste glaube ich auch nicht gut gehen wobei mir bei der bahn ja
noch klar ist die können ja da gar nichts für die normalen leute bei der bahn können gar nichts
für die management entscheidung der bahn und ich glaube es würde bei der bahn noch viel schlechter
laufen wenn sich nicht tagtäglich ganz viele leute bei der bahn mühe geben würden dass es
eben so gut läuft obwohl das drumherum nicht stimmt fertig mit operation operative profession nice
warum hast du das gemacht versprichst du dir da irgendwie bessere job möglichkeiten mehr
geld vielleicht hast du auch schon irgendwie bei einem arbeitgeber was ausgemacht also wie
bist du dazu gekommen das zu machen c++ im hardwarebereich ist doch unersetzlich ja leider
leider gerade gerade embedded sachen ist es c oder c++ bis wir da rast häufig sehen wird
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern wenn überhaupt auch wenn es dafür eigentlich ganz
gut geeignet wäre leider leider ja es ist es ist es ist immer ein ganz großer qual für mich wenn
ich sp sachen programmieren muss und c++ machen muss das immer schlimm der typ ist egal hat sich
bei mir in den kommentaren einer aufgeregt dass ich c++ flamme indirekt hat er sich aufgeregt
dass ich c++ flamme hat geschrieben ich würde mich immer unqualifiziert über programmier sprachen
äußern auf twitter von denen ich gar keine ahnung habe oder sowas in der richtung und damit meint er
natürlich c++ was sonst aber ich habe damit keine probleme gegen c++ zu renten auch wenn ich nicht
100 prozentig durchblicke in c++ weil der witz ist ja es gibt niemand der in c++ richtig gut durchblick
nicht mal das gremium selbst ihr müsst euch angucken was in den letzten c++ standards reingekommen
ist und wie widersprüchlich das an vielen stellen untereinander ist das nichts einheitlich das heißt
für mich nicht einmal das c++ gremium hat ahnung von c++ ja das ist gut gut ist gut ist gut das ist
das einzig ertragbare an c++ so
hoffentlich schaffe ich den chat heute noch mal irgendwann
fertig zu lesen aber ich bin total weit hinten dran hast du das bauer video vom
hetzen bei hetze gesehen haben wir uns letztens vorletzten sonntag glaube ich sogar schon
angeguckt server bauen und verkabeln also server verkabeln und also server bauen nicht aber
sogar einbauen verkabeln ist je nachdem wo du arbeitest auch großer bestandteil von einer
fisi ausbildung max was sagst du zum wieder einmal ist es mal wieder soweit dass es fachkräftemangel
angeblich gibt zum wieder einmal propagierten fachkräftemangel für den allen nur zuwanderung
als lösung sehen ich sehe das eine mit dem anderen hat gar nicht so sehr damit was zu tun
ehrlich gesagt die wollen die doch nur aus dem auswahl weil es billiger ist ich weiß das weiß
ich nicht die könnten ja dem die müssten ja auch also wenn es danach geht müsste man ja auch kein
leute aus dem aushalt holen weil es billiger ist da können wir das einfach aus so outsourcen nach
indien polen oder sonst wie und selbst dort macht man das nicht mehr wirklich gerne mittlerweile
der trend geht ja dahin dass man sachen die ausgesaust sind eher wieder einsaust wie nennt
man das dann eigentlich hat man das dann ein einsaust der fachkräftemangel ist real allerdings nur unter
den voraussetzungen wie dass die leute klassifizieren die dafür zuständig sind dass er bei uns also
zum beispiel bitte kommen ist ja so ein laden der macht das gerne oder auch das arbeitsamt macht
das ja gerne mit fachkräftemangel bei denen ist ein fachkräftemangel wenn es quasi lange zeit
stellen gibt die nicht besetzt werden können also wenn es wenn es quasi mehr stellen gibt und das
an langfristig als sie die besetzt werden können ist es ein fachkräftemangel allerdings was dort
nicht hinterfragt wird ist könnte das vielleicht auch daran liegen dass die leute die diese stellen
ausschreiben unrealistische anforderungen haben oder unrealistische bedingungen stellen oder eben
unattraktiv sind für bewerber das wird er da überhaupt nicht bei berücksichtigt ja es ist
oftmals schwierig leute zu bekommen das merke ich bei uns auch die suchen auch teilweise händrigen
leute und finden kein aber da muss man dazu sagen unsere stellenanzeigen gerade habe ich euch ja
mal erzählt dafür in support und sowas wo sie leute suchen für 25 sieben die sind schlecht da
würde ich mich nie im leben bewerben das habe ich damals dem dem damaligen teamleiter geschrieben
ich habe sogar noch vorschläge dahinter hinter hinter geschrieben wie man das wie man das umschreiben
könnte ja zum beispiel nicht einfach irgendwie die hatten auch so eine stellenanzeige da stand so
sinnloses zeug drin so nach dem motto arbeiten beim topunternehmen in dieser branche irgendwie
sowas sinngemäßes who cares ja da muss dann rein stehen da muss dann sowas drinne stehen wie freie
betriebssystem auswahl höhenverstellbarer schreibtisch kantine im haus kinderbetreuung
also wenn man es hat ja sowas muss da reinschreiben was ganz ehrlich was juckt es mich als bewerbung
als als positiver punkt arbeiten bei bei einem was weiß ich bei einer branchengröße oder sowas
who cares das ist mir doch scheiß egal ja ich will wirklich wissen was ist da was was ist da sinnvolle
vorteile für mich gibt ja dass man ein kostenloses job ticket bekommt vielleicht oder sowas oder
gute anbindung irgendwas was für meinen täglichen arbeitstag relevant ist will ich da hören was
mich anspricht mich spricht nicht an wenn da drinne steht wir sind der größte im bla bla bla
bereich hat es jemals von euch jemals schon überzeugt die ganzen stellenanzeigen fangen
ja immer an mit mindestens fünf setzen selbstbeweihräucherung und danach kommt
dann auch bei pluspunkten oftmals so dinge wie was weiß ich der top platziert in der
finanzdienstleistungsbranche und irgendwie so komisches zeug oder ein tolles team oder
irgendwie so so so komplett ja wen wen juckt ob das wirklich so ist also ob das ein tolles team
ist das muss ich ja dann entscheiden letztendlich und wenn es halt auf diese anzeigen dann keine
bewerber gibt mir lange oft offensinn dann kommt dann halt dazu dass es dort als fachkräftemangel
gesehen wird und letztendlich sind alle immer führend wenn ihr stellt anzeigen einfach führend
im bereich xy führen in dem bereich sonst wie ganz vorne nummer eins die top die besten sowieso
das schreiben sie alle es können aber nicht alle die beste sein das funktioniert überhaupt nicht
müssen sich eigentlich auch gar nicht es geht darum wenn du bewerber ansprechen willst dass
der job attraktiv ist ob das jetzt führen im bereich xy ist mir persönlich vollkommen scheiß
egal so und deswegen kommt es dann zum fachkräftemangel weil eben stellen offen sind die aus welchen
gründen auch immer keine sau machen will zu wenig bezahlung zu unattraktive arbeitgeber aus
irgendwelchen gründen ja nicht genug vorteile oder mehr nachteile als vorteile alles in kombination
dass da keiner sich drauf bewerben will und dann ist es fachkräftemangel ist es ja nicht es gibt
genug leute du findest leute du musst den leuten bloß was bieten dass sie zu dir gehen und nicht
zu was anderem und da muss man ehrlich sagen das ist für uns die in dieser branche arbeiten
eigentlich der beste zustand den man haben kann klar du musst dich immer noch quasi bewerben also
du musst die auch überzeugen aber in der heutigen zeit ist es eben auch so dass nicht nur du die
überzeugen muss sondern dass auch die dich überzeugen müssen dass du nicht mehr hingehen
kannst und nach dem motto ja ich muss euch in den arsch kriechen und ihr müsst nix machen das ist
heute halt nicht mehr so das ist eigentlich für uns das beste was dir was einem passieren kann
schon von templo es gehört klar da habe ich schon die werden und nichts eher gefahren werden
und nicht von templo es gehört ja ob man als zuwanderung für braucht oder nicht sage ich mal
leicht mal dahingestellt ich denke dass es durchaus was helfen kann dann muss man allerdings sagen also
erstens erst mal ganz klar gesagt die meisten leute da gibt es gab es gibt gibt es ja sogar
dass ob weiß ich ob es umfragen sind studien die studien sind eher umfragen also viele wollen ja
gar nicht zu uns also wenn die jetzt beispielsweise mal in länder gehen was weiß ich europäische
länder oder auch was weiß ich im asiatischen raum im raum oder so die wollen ja gar nicht zu
uns die haben die irgendwie so was soll ich denn in deutschland und wenn man jetzt sagt okay wir
wollen vielleicht in der holen oder sonst was ja klar man muss dann aber gucken dass man qualifizierte
leute holt dann können die sicherlich auch dazu beitragen das problem ein bisschen auf zu lockern
oder zu lösen aber ich glaube in der masse gibt es da gar nicht so viele da wirklich bock
drauf haben zu uns zu kommen und das zu machen also die mal ist es eher um die masse der leute
die wir bekommen sind nicht wirklich für it arbeiten ausgebildet und außerdem würde ich
auch eher in die schweiz geht da gibt es noch mehr geld ich würde am liebsten deutschland
wohnen oft in der schweiz geld verdient ja ich glaube dass das noch eine ganze weile bestand
haben wird dass es mehr stellen gibt gerade jetzt ihr müsst euch mal überlegen wie viele jetzt
da komplett davon überrascht worden sind dass diese sache mit mit home office so nach dem motto
fack wir müssen jetzt unseren mitarbeitern auch wenn es nur 20 sind die möglichkeit bieten oder
die möglichkeit irgendwie bereitstellen dass sie von zu hause arbeiten können und wir haben keine
leute wir haben irgendwie einen turnschuh admin der außer winners active direkt du geklickt nix
kann fack wir brauchen leute oder wir sollten uns vielleicht mal gescheit bezahlen und hätten
wir uns anatmen mal gescheit bezahlt er wäre nicht weggerannt die haben halt gelitten ja und wer
da eben es nicht schafft attraktive stellen zu schaffen dass die leute machen wollen der hat
halt pech so ist es halt gelitten und ich habe letztens erst wieder artikel gelesen darüber dass
es in deutschland ich glaube hauptsächlich auch in berlin dass es relativ viele oder was hamburg
noch hamburg gewinnt dass es relativ viele startups gibt in deutschland allerdings nicht
etwas startups wie man jetzt das vielleicht aus anderen ländern kennt vielleicht aus irgendwelchen
trend branchen ja sei es jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich biofleisch aus dem reagenz class oder
irgendwas oder irgendwie themen der zukunft nein nein wir haben ganz viele startups die sich
darauf spezialisiert haben den ollen eingesessenen uralt boomer geführten unternehmen die neue
technik näher zu bringen also die die jetzt fax schicken die wollen irgendwann auch mal instant
messenger verwenden und da haben wir ganz viele startups die sich da mittlerweile darauf
spezialisiert haben das zu machen das boomt natürlich auch weil wir haben halt so viele
rückständige leden in deutschland muss ich mal überlegen dass korona zahlen teilweise
zwei drei tage verzögert sind weil sie sich bis heute noch fax schicken also das ist wirklich der
wahnsinn
naja also oracle ist im enterprise umfeld immer noch somit das beliebteste also ich würde sagen
so im enterprise umfeld ist es meistens so dass in der regel versucht man eigentlich sich da auf
einen datenbank typ einzuschießen außer bei uns wir haben 580 verschiedene datenbank typen aber
normalerweise sagt man hey wir möchten eigentlich nur also wir haben expertise in dem bereich und
die bauen wir aus und wollen nicht 50 verschiedene datenbanken und oracle ist da tatsächlich im
enterprise umfeld immer noch relativ beliebt auch wenn die lizenzen fucking teuer sind und die
lizenzierungspolitik für den arsch ist ich weiß ich ob das heute noch so ist aber so eine so kleine
kleine story was oracle lizenzen angeht wenn ihr eine oracle datenbank betreiben wollt und sagt
auch gut ich betreibe die oracle datenbank auf einer vm und ihr gibt der vm 2 cpu kerne der es
x unten drunter hat aber 32 cpu kerne was meint ihr für wie viel cpu kerne ihr oracle lizenzieren
müsst für 2 oder für 32 für 32 korrekt was halt auch komplett für den arsch ist du hast
eine vm die nur 2 benutzen kann aber nein ja ja und das ganze lässt sich umgehen in dem man die
oracle entweder die oracle cloud nimmt oder die oracle basierte virtualisierung also weiß gar nicht
wie die oracle wie heißt die oracle virtualisierung noch mal das ist irgendwas auf unbreakable das
heißt wirklich so ist kein witz wisst ihr wisst ihr wie das wisst ihr wie das oracle wie das wie
das linux von oracle heißt unbreakable linux heißt das ok vielleicht heißt es nicht mehr so
aber es hieß früher so unbreakable linux heißt das ja und wenn du das damit machst mit der
virtualisierung die das verwendet dann musst du nur die nur die kleineren kerne bezahlen
also echt der witz oracle lizenzierung aber ich würde also man müsste mal man müsste mal
vielleicht kennt einer von euch eine gute statistik aber ich würde sagen datenbacken
im enterprise umfeld oracle leider microsoft sql es gibt halt ganz viele windows und ja
microsoft fans auf dieser welt also ich würde sagen oracle microsoft sql vielleicht oldschool
db2 zeug noch vereinzelt und postgres und halt web by sql aber ich würde sagen oracle und
microsoft sql ist da wahrscheinlich vorne rate ich jetzt ich weiß nicht ob es stimmt
ist das ein modifiziertes red hat ja ist es gaming stühle sind müll ich hatte auch mal
einen dx racer und da ist die stuhl die armlehne ist aus dem rahmen rausgebrochen als ich mal
so zackig aufgestanden bin und mein ja ich bin ich der schlankste aber das metall sollte
nicht wirklich abreißen eventuell eine blöde anfänger frage was bedeutet könne beziehungs
könne powerfehler sagt mir so nix hey kenne dich von damals mit einem alten battlefield
3 wie das fand es immer interessant dass du die kleinen show was wir umfangen auch das
in frankfurt ja gibt es bestimmt noch mehr was muss du erzählen mal langsam bisschen
ranz krollen ja das wäre nicht schlecht ai die für mich tickets bearbeit ja gut mongo
db no sql habe ich jetzt mal gar nicht mitgezählt hier sind wir erst das ist eine halbe stunde
schon her null historisch gewachsen ja so nennt man das bei uns auch bin gerade auf
einem beruflichen gymnasium wo ich uml und java lerne glaubst du dass es mir etwas bringen
wird wenn ich mich auf ein duales studium bewerbe java wird ja auf jeden fall was bringen
java ist an der uni noch sehr beliebt uml kann ich nichts zu sagen keine ahnung ob
man uml in irgendeiner art und weise da braucht man ist discord alternativen testen einer
nächsten streams ja z ist gar nicht das problem z plus plus ist das problem schon klatsche
sein für den sub kannst du einstellen aber nicht dass sie das machen was sagst du zu
direkt access sagt mir nix in welchem zusammenhang ich muss jetzt erst mal beim chat runter
scrollen sonst wird es ja gar nichts mehr war ja gar nicht noch beta ich weiß nicht ob
war ja gar mittlerweile im körner gelandet ist die sie sollten ja mal und dann wieder
nicht und dann wird sie irgendwie aus bsd wieder ausgebaut oder so ach keine ahnung
leg ich da mal durch warum kopierst du ständig buchstaben weil ich das gerne mache checkpoint
ich hatte mal hatte jemand mal das vergnügen mit checkpoint firewall 1 jetzt jawoll so
so in der richtung sah das so in der richtung sah das aus ja da kann ich mich noch dran
erinnern checkpoint checkpoint firewall 1 das war meines wissens nach hatte checkpoint
die erste state voll firewall der welt damals damals ist wirklich ja das kenne ich noch
und damals ist wirklich 90 100 was weiß ich 90 oder so gemeint ja war verses die scharp
aber unter dem strich nimmt sich das eigentlich nicht so viel wenn du willst dass deine software
in china groß rauskommt dann im java die china die china chinesen stehen nämlich sehr
auf java und nicht so sehr auf sie schab da hat's microsoft bisschen verpennt ist pyson
irgendwie ein meme hat man vortrag von einem dude geäußert er das geflamen du kannst
nahezu alles flamen du kannst java script flamen du kannst pyson flamen du kannst die
scharp flamen du kannst hier plus plus flamen du kannst alles flamen du wirst du wirst an
allem irgendwas finden was kacke ist und sicherlich wirst du bei pyson auch einiges finden was
kacke ist fängt ja schon mal mit der geschwindigkeit an wobei das gar nicht so schlimm ist weil
vieles der wirklich performance kritischen sachen ist halt nicht in pyson selbst programmiert
sondern als irgendwelche c-module aber du findest am pyson sicherlich auch vieles was
müll ist ja das ist übrigens wieder das beste beispiel für cute ist prog slot signal system
ja das ist gut aber man sieht wieder daran dass wäre mit reinem c++ nicht möglich gewesen
weil c++ undurchdachter shit ist ja und zu temple os wie gesagt das gucken wir uns nicht
im stream an da gibt es jetzt nicht so viel spannendes bei klar das kenne ich das kennt
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile fast fast jeder leider ist der programmierer gestorben mittlerweile
der hatte aber einen heftigen dachschaden ich weiß nicht ob es dort jetzt mehrere details
mittlerweile zu gibt ob der temple os typ freiwillig von zug gelaufen ist besoffen war oder irgendwie
einfach nur durch keine ahnung der typ der war wirklich der war wirklich komplett fertig
im kopf übrigens temple os ist entstanden weil er angeblich eine vision oder sowas
hatte also gott hat ihm sagt er sagt er gott hat ihm aufgetragen sein betriebssystem braucht
keine ahnung 8 bit farbtiefe muss in holy c programmiert sein und braucht den 46 mal
480 gui das ist jetzt kein witz das hat ihm gott angeblich so übermittelt wie auch immer
das funktioniert also der kell hat doch schon hatte der war doch schon ziemlich gestört
thema os war ich würde auf der arbeit lieben gerne mit einem mangaro nutzen und es spricht
eigentlich nichts wirklich dagegen das einzige was mich davon abhalten könnte ist das programmierungstool
welches unter windows 95 geschrieben wurde das gibt es nur für windows aber das läuft
mit wine perfekt
wissen wir also wenn du wenn du wenn du wirklich windows software braucht und ihr hauptsächlich
in den windows laden seit was spricht dagegen mangaro in vm zu packen ich würde mangaro
in vm packen und wenn das gar nicht geht würde ich würde ich halt wsl verwenden aber auch
wenn wsl ziemlich cool ist mittlerweile ich bevorzuge immer noch ein komplettes system
in der vm keine ahnung
keine ahnung oh wir haben es fast geschafft mit dem chat
eure lizenzen ich meine man sieht man sieht bei eure lizenzen und bei microsoft lizenzen
ja schon mal eins das ist ja absichtlich dass das alles so undurchsichtig ist weil
da hat sich ja ein komplett eigener markt an beratern für lizenzen etabliert und durchgesetzt
mittlerweile allein schon wenn man einen komplett eigenen berater markt für lizenzen hat da
sieht man dass irgendwas nicht stimmt
ja unbreakable linux von oracle ist ein monkaS ja ja ist ein system auf rettet basis firebird
sql ok das habe ich schon lange nicht mal gehört sap habe ich zum glück nie was mit
zu tun gehabt will ich auch nicht mongo db neu sql ja wir haben eine mongo wir haben
eine mongo db enterprise lizenz und wisst ihr ich habe eine mongo db aufkleber auf meinem
notebook weil wir die enterprise lizenz haben wir haben uns kostenlose aufkleber geschickt
habe ich mir gedacht excellent da muss ich mir gleich aufkleber drauf machen ich meine
wahrscheinlich haben wir irgendwie keine ahnung 300.000 euro für die lizenzen bezahlt
oder so aber so ein aufkleber sollte schon mal drin sein oder
mongo db datenbank für vpn wie viele user gehen über deinen vpn dass du eine eigene
db für die user brauchst ab welchen skalierungsgrößen also von was reden wir hier ich kann mir das
schlecht vorstellen also warum brauchst du eine datenbank für die für die vpn user
ok wenn ich den vpn anbieter bin und irgendwie 50.000 kunden oder so ok das verstehe ich
um 11 wird an unis auch gemacht na gut alter jetzt wird die musik ein bisschen zu aufdringlich
warum kopierst du ständig buchstaben ja wie gesagt habe ich mir so angewöhnt das mache
ich mache ich gerne copy link to highlight was kommt denn da jetzt raus das wird doch
im leben nicht funktionieren funktioniert auch nicht kacke feature ja genau da gibt es ich
habe da schon mal was zu aufgenommen warum ich buchstaben kopiere ist seit 56 im körner
ok ich weiß dass ein bisschen hickhack gegeben hat was wir schach im minus körner angingen
danke für den sub x x x l l x x x l l huge subscriptions ja rast ist also rast brauchst
du mindestens 140 eq drunter kannst vergessen der package manager ist müll das wusste ich
nicht das ist gar kein stream hier das kann ich nicht auf twitch ausprobieren nachdem
was das ist keine ahnung wenn ich das in titel schreibe mit mein stream gebannt durch irgendwelche
eis vm ist gut dafür auch wenn es ja also ich würde auch des linux unter unter da vm installieren
ich habe den chat jawoll ich habe es geschafft durchgescrollt exzellent es hat es nur eine
stunde 15 gedauert was für ein ding britt britt schon was was für ein ding ok habe
ich noch nie gehört habe ich legit noch nie gehört ich kann wissen wie man das aussprechen
soll britt britt und tunnel tunnel tunnel irgendwas mit tunnel keine ahnung vier stück
oh doch soviel für c++ reicht kein eq der welt weil eq bringt dir nur was wenn was logisch
ist und c++ ist nicht logisch kennst du dich mit filesystem aus zfs ist ja nicht im linux
ist nicht im köln von links da macht es sinn btfs zu verwenden zu zfs kann ich euch was
schönes zeigen ubuntu hat ein bug in zfs als der filesystem geschrottet hat
wenn man das wenn man das jetzt irgendwie finden würde ich bin hier in den news nix
broken update also es gab in der letzten ubuntu version wenn man geupgraded hat gab es einen
bug und der hat weiß ich ob das hier der link dazu ist please must do not upgrade to ubuntu
21 10 wir wissen ja alles heißt ja korrekt ausgesprochen jubantu ich finde meine finde
meine text-to-speech-dinger nicht nicht ich habe mir ja noch irgendwie genau also es gibt
anscheinend irgendeinen bug wenn man zfs upgraded dass das dann silent das filesystem korruptet
und die platten kaputt macht unrecoverable weiß ich wie ich das auf deutsch sagen soll
nicht wieder herstellbar ja das ist das problem bei dingern die nicht im kernel sind wobei
die dieser bug theoretisch auch passieren könnte wenn das im köln wäre wobei die
chancen deutlich geringer sind aber es einfach bei den ubuntu leute nicht richtig getest
wurde du hast geupgraded ja also das ist tatsächlich gerade gefährlich das letzte video habe
ich nicht gezogen nicht nicht nicht gesehen keine ahnung also du kannst auch btfs verwenden
das ist jetzt aber auch nicht so dass wo was wirklich krass supportet wird oder so das
ist halt einfach da aber viele große herrschen ich glaube rett hat mittlerweile sogar btfs
den support eingestellt oder so das ist kein das ist nicht mehr das system auf btfs unterstützt
also ganz ehrlich ich würde lieber auf zfs setzen als auf btfs einfach weil es das deutlich
verbreitet deutlich länger im einsatz ist oder von den features her besser ist und spätestens
mit eingebauten encryption noch mal richtig cooles neues feature bekommen hat ich weiß
gar nicht wie weit die sind mit on the fly erweiterung dass du mittlerweile auch extenden
kannst und nicht immer nur neue volumes anlegen ich habe mich da eine weile schon nicht mal
mit beschäftigt aber ich würde jetzt immer noch zfs verwenden die frage ist aber warum
also wenn du einfach nur eine festplatte hast und dort was drauf speichern willst ohne dass
du jetzt irgendwelche spezialanforderungen hast würde ich da auch kein zfs drauf machen
sondern ganz normalen x4 oder xfs was ist zfs ein filesystem ein filesystem mit ziemlich
coolen features beispielsweise sind so art sind rate funktion eingebaut verschlüsselungsfunktion
checks um dass die dateien nicht kaputt oder zu checken ob die dateien kaputt sind ob seit
sync ist relativ einfach also zfs hat viele coole features schon mal mit asher devops
ja aber nicht wirklich viel ehrlich gesagt habe ich das in mein asher meine asher devops
erfahrung endet bei dem was wir auf so einer microsoft schulung gemacht haben und das hat
mich nicht sonderlich geschockt als möchte ich damit was weitermachen zum glück haben
wir bei uns auf der arbeit jetzt auch diesen ganzen mist mit asher devops gar nicht angefangen
sondern machen es direkt über github und github actions und da bin ich deutlich aufgeschlossener
gegenüber zumal ich davon auch schon ein bisschen ahnung habe wir haben hier sogar im stream
schon github actions gemacht wann kommen motge zurück ich glaube wir hatten nie motge als
emote ich habe nix entfernt willst du dich zum drachen lord äußern seuchte was willst du
dazu was soll ich dazu sagen ich habe das mitbekommen ich kenne aber die genauen umstände
nicht woran er einem irgendwie ein stein vor den kopf gehauen hat ob das bei ihm auf dem
kunststück war oder auf der gas oder sonst wie interessiert mich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
so großartig wir haben es geschafft nie zfs ist nicht neu zfs ist irgendwie 20 jahre alt
oder so ich habe die mail von heute nicht gelesen wo muss man rüber switchen also zu
github meinst du ja ja die übertreiben es gerade ein bisschen mit der geschwindigkeit
das wird beinigt bis ende des jahres wie soll das funktionieren also zfs ist schon ziemlich
alt zfs ist von 1985 oder so keine ahnung hier 2006 so jung ich dachte zfs ist älter
also jung in anführungsstrichen aber zfs ist schon relativ relativ alt man muss allerdings
unterscheiden es gibt ja quasi das ursprüngliche zfs von oracle nämlich orikels an san ganz
wichtig san nicht oracle san und dann gibt es den teil den sie irgendwann mal open source
gemacht haben und dann haben sie wieder close source gemacht und weiterentwickelt so und
jetzt ist es so dass die linux leute von open zfs haben eine kam quasi meines wissens nach
die damalige source implementierung genommen und bauen jetzt eigene funktionen ein und
mittlerweile ist das eigentlich fast schon besser als das originale von features her
zumindest also ist echt cool allerdings ziemlich komplex und ich würde nicht einfach zfs machen
nur weil ich eine externe festplatte habe wo was drauf muss ja kann man eigentlich ganz
gut vergleichen ja bei github actions legst du auch eine jammel datei in einem repo an
wo dann drin steht was passieren soll ja ist relativ kann man gut damit vergleichen soll
ich mir das letzte video von linux test test checktips mal angucken mit zfs wir können
uns das mal welches welches denn das nicht das ist ja schon älter welches davon hat
mit zfs zu tun gut bei windows ich frag mich immer ob die ihren kram wirklich auf diesem
selbst gestrickten kram laufen haben oder ob das alles nur show für die für die show
ist letztendlich 21 minuten oh nee ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich bin kein großer linux
tech tips fan denn ich finde die videos nicht so spannend waren die denn da überhaupt
und die mal wirklich zfs kram ach die haben dann die haben den freenas wobei tunas ist
das neue freenas ja gut das ist ja noch mal das ist ja mal noch mal eine stufe einfacher
die die sache ist plus die was machen die jetzt wenn da wirklich mal was kaputt geht
und sie was von hand machen müssen zum beispiel stellt euch noch mal vor die haben da irgendwie
keine ahnung 20 20 disks drinne und müssten das mal an einem anderen rechner zum laufen
zu bekommen das ist kein ding das funktioniert aber also ja ich bin da ich bin da kein fan
mein mittlerpfeile von von unnötig komplexen systemen für eigentlich relativ easy anforderungen
wahrscheinlich wir für die den ssd storage sogar noch mit das beste wenn es um die geschwindigkeit
geht also wenn die die geschwindigkeit haben wollen also deswegen irgendwelche sachen gemirrert
haben oder was auch immer dann sollen sie sich einfach ssd storage nehmen ach das ist
ssd storage ja dann ja also ganz ehrlich wenn die das zum größten teil als ja so feil
sind nicht so als als ablage verwenden dann würde ich noch nicht mal ein klassisches
rate machen da würde ich einfach die ssd nehmen und gar nichts ich würde einfach in
groß ich würde ich würde ich würde einfach eine große platte draus machen aber nur rein
high level technisch wenn ich denn überhaupt was selbst machen möchte sodass unten drunter
halt immer noch auf einzelnen platten ist dass da gar nichts gespiegelt wird oder sonst
was dass du im zweifelsfall doch einfach die platte nehmen kannst in anderen rechner stecken
und dann ist wieder alles da und ich würde einfach einmal nachts oder meinetwegen auch
alle zwei stunden oder wie auch immer inkrementelles backup machen da würde ich noch nicht mal
großartige rate geschichten machen ehrlich gesagt je nachdem wie viele platten das das
sind jetzt weil im schlimmsten fall sind die dateien von einer ssd weg die tauscht
da außen macht es aus dem backup wieder draus das dürfte wahrscheinlich vom anwendungsfall
her das einfachste sein und man braucht keine super spezialkenntnisse für also rate kann
auch teilweise tückisch sein wenn man nicht so genau weiß was man treibt jetzt hätte
es lohnt sich vor allem wenn man die zfs features haben möchte ja jetzt nicht unbedingt die
duplication da ist zfs geht zwar ist aber ramm technisch nicht relevant zum beispiel
eingebaute verschlüsselung haben will oder oft seit backup oder sowas einfachen zynk
solche dingen also wenn man wenn man die coolen zfs einfach nur als fileserver weil man da
paar große dateien drauf hat ich weiß ich nicht könntest du mal deine heizungssteuerung
zeigen sekunde ich kann den bild von meiner heizungssteuerung zeigen meiner müsste ich
mein home assistant aufmachen und will ich nicht da liege ich zu viel aber ich kann dir
zeigen wie jetzt meine heizungssteuerung aussieht so sieht die jetzt aus das ist meine heizungssteuerung
jetzt so sieht das ist aus direkt aus dem home assistant dashboard copy pasted kannst
einstellen die die temperatur was die heizung als raumtemperatur haben soll du siehst ausgelesen
die aktuelle temperatur das wird einem thermostat im flur gemessen weil im flur ist ein ganz guter
indikator wie warms im haus ist dann ob sparbetrieb oder nicht und ich glaube 23 uhr schaltet sich das
um 22 grad ist noch nicht kalt 22 grad ist noch vollkommen in ordnung also minus 22 kann ja
der chat so du kannst ausschalten oder auf heizen schalten fertig und ich habe halt noch
ein thermostat an den einzelnen heiz also an den einzelnen heizkörpern bei mir ist gerade ich
habe das hier gerade 24 grad gestellt bei mir im zimmer ist auch ja fast 24 grad so
sechs leute darauf editieren mit ssd sollte das eigentlich kein problem sein gerade wenn
du die festplatten wenn du die ssd wenn du so machst dass die dateien über die ssd vielleicht
verteilt sind oder jeder auf seine eigenen ssd oder was auch immer landet dann wäre das nicht so
das problem ne kraft warne habe ich gerade noch nicht also ich habe ja einen prometheuse exporter
gebastelt für meine heizungsgeschichten aber das habe ich gerade noch nicht wieder eingeschaltet
nächsten monat sind winterprüfung kannst du mal eine aufgabe ip oh nee das kann ich nicht mehr du
kannst gerne schicken aber ich kann das nicht mehr ich habe das ich habe das voll verlernt
ich weiß noch slash 24 also ich kriege slash 10 kriege ich in slash 16 und slash 24 aber
ansonsten kein slash acht mal oder acht glaube ich meine ich das kriege nicht mehr hin mit
classless inter domain routing jetzt auch so oder warum bevorzugt bgp routen mit längeren
subnet maske für dieselbe ip range keine ahnung ist das so das kommt wahrscheinlich
darauf an wie man eingestellt hat wie er die prioritäten aus aus aus machen soll wenn du
mehrere routen hast die zum gleichen ziel führen da muss ich der router ja irgendwie
überlegen welche er nimmt und eventuell ist ja die default einstellung irgendwas mit subnet
maske oder keine ahnung weiß ich nicht warum das so ist falls das so ist wie gesagt es
ist plus minus 22 grad ja du meistens kannst du ja also das ist übrigens ein vorteil für
zfs und linux software rate du bist nicht vom rate controller abhängig ja rate controller
gehen in der tat allerdings relativ selten kaputt und man kann sie meistens auch austauschen
gegen einen vom gleichen typ aber das macht tatsächlich öfters mal probleme da bin ich
kein so großer fan von also wenn ich einfach nur eine externe festplatte haben will dann
machst du lux verschlüsseln und gut ist aber lux und danach in verbindung noch mit md rate
und lvm ich weiß nicht da ist es auch wieder so viele stellen wo wo man sich mit auskennen
muss und pains champ und nee keine ahnung ich habe mit spiele programmierung keine ahnung
so ja das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an so zfs habe ich euch gezeigt was hatten wir
hier eigentlich noch auf heine sorts bevor launch alter es ist noch zwei wochen drei wochen hin wetten
mit ich wette mit euch der keller macht noch drei solcher videos so final thoughts bevor launch
final jetzt really final thoughts bevor launch last bla bla bla bevor launch tomorrow launch last
final thoughts der macht bestimmt noch 50 solcher videos davor laudes pc ever ok
moment moment moment sec sec ah es muss zur
leder stehen das ist ach das sind alle alle ausgemusterte server ja gut da kann schon mal
was im arsch sein außerdem sind die dinge an sich auch ziemlich laut hier ist eine prüfung
aufgabe aber gleich mal gucken alter weil was hat er denn da für einen berg bitteschön stehen
so hier prüfungsaufgabe sec also whoops musik oh je oh nee oh nee please please nein ich mache
jetzt kein subnetting das haben wir denn bei den anlagen wird an einer station immer ein host mit
25 intelligenten sensoren aktoren in ein subnetz gelegt alter ist das ihk sind das ihk fragen das
ist so typische ihk frage wurde immer direkt so alter was wollte überhaupt von mir also ein host
mit 25 intelligenten sensoren aktoren in einer in in ein subnetz gelegt jeder sensor verfügt über
ein netzwerk interface ihr netzwerkadministrator gibt ihnen das netz 10 10 1 9 4 0 slash 24 vor
sie als 24 das ist ja noch relativ einfach sie bekommen die aufgabe das netz hierfür aufzuteilen
ah du sollst du sollst ab du sollst das noch mal du sollst du sollst zittere zittere machen
du sollst das hier machen klasse less inter domain routing zittere nicht nicht irgendwie
spanischer wein oder so heißt ja auch so ähnlich ein klasse das inter domain routing wobei ist das
überhaupt spanisch so berechnen sie die maximale anzahl an stationen die betrieben werden können
wenn jede station in einem ein oder nee nee da habe ich jetzt wirklich keinen bock drauf
da habe ich jetzt echt das ist wahrscheinlich das ist total einfach aber da habe ich jetzt echt kein
nerv drauf brechen sie für die ersten drei subnetz jeweils die netzadresse gut die netzadresse am
anfang ist einfach die ist null beim nächsten netz wird es dann schon ein bisschen komplizierter
na gut also es ist ok das kriegt es das kriegen wir hin welches welches netz brauchen wir denn
seck ich mache es mir zwar ein bisschen einfacher welches welches netz brauchen wir denn um 25
host rein zu bekommen was ist denn das also sind schlecht 32 kann es ja schon mal nicht sein 31
und 30 sind definitiv auch zu klein keine ahnung vielleicht aus dem kopf die 26 oder so vielleicht
ip kalk ip kalk 10 punkt 10 punkt 10 punkt 10 10 punkt 0 slash 24 slash 25 slash 26 27 27 klingt
gut ja 27 wollen du willst in 27 haben du willst in 27 haben da kriegst du das dann rein und ja gut
ab dann ist es ja im prinzip noch zählen die erste netzwerk adresse ist null hinten broadcast adresse
ist 31 das heißt die nächste netzwerk adresse ist 32 und dann plus 30 und das ist dann broadcast
eins dazu ist wieder das daran kann man sich dann lang hangeln gut du hast dann du hast dann keinen
rechner aber das ist das ist kein ding da musste dann halt rechnen keine ahnung 2 hoch 4 2 hoch 5 2
hoch 6 und guckst dann einfach am besten was rein passt 2 5 ist es in 32 32 minus 2 kannst du abziehen
weil broadcast und netz adresse dann hast du noch 30 für die host übrig und du weißt du brauchst
fünf bits für die host das bedeutet du brauchst drei bits für die subnet maske und das ist dann
quasi ein 255 255 255 224 das hätte ich jetzt aus dem kopf nicht gewusst winnie danke für den
sub also das ist jetzt dass es hinten 224 hat das hätte ich jetzt nicht gewusst aus dem kopf
ich habe das auch nicht aus dem kopf gewusst ich habe sie in kalk eingegeben so was haben wir
hier sonst als nächstes noch berechnen sie für die ersten drei sappen ja gut das haben wir
ja gerade gemacht ja das haben wir gerade gemacht also es ist es ist es ist netzwerk null 31 nächste
ist dann 32 netz und das dann plus 30 plus drauf für broadcast und dann wieder eins weiter
so mehrere stationen werden an einem switch angebunden um die stationen von analogisch zu
trennen soll dieser switch auf layer 2 mit hilfe von wie lands aufgeteilt werden ja die
rk steht auf dieses layer geschissen jetzt ich warte darauf bis der chat wieder ankommt es
gibt auch layer 3 switch und da muss ich wieder sagen nein chat es gibt keine layer 3 switch
switching ist sowas von layer 2 es gibt geräte die layer 3 funktionalität vielleicht haben aber
das switching an sich was der switch macht ist immer layer 2 wie soll er den layer 3 switching
aussehen überhaupt das ergibt keinen sinn dass man könnte fast schon sagen layer 3 switch ist
halt ja kombi gerät aus switch plus noch ein paar management features manche können ja manche
layer 3 switch sind ja im prinzip sogar router die zwischen verschiedenen netzen das war dann
dann nicht sonderlich schnell weil die cpu dafür nicht gedacht ist in drinnen und das oftmals
auch nur in software passiert und gar nicht irgendwie hardware optimiert mit den passenden
mit der passenden hardware drinnen aber das switching an sich ist immer layer 2 das hat
mit layer 3 nix zu tun deswegen ist layer 3 switch eigentlich somit das miss wie soll man sagen so
missverständlichste bezeichnung überhaupt so um um die station voneinander logisch zu
trennen soll diese switch auf layers was auf layer 2 mit hilf von wieder ins aufgeteilt werden ja
ok ich habe nicht mal an was sie lernen dass das osi modell man das osi modell das kennt man
doch wenn man sowas gelernte hier guck mal das osi modell hier war das please do not throw salami
pizza away don't throw salami pizza nee please do do please do not throw salami pizza away als
merksatz für osi ja hier da guck please do not throw salami pizza away ich habs mir gemerkt ja
das osi modell reicht wieder oder sollte man doch subnetzen das eine das ist die es ist gar nicht die
frage entweder oder subnetzen bringt dir nix wenn du nicht willst dass die eigentlich also muss ich
muss ich muss ich anders anfangen also du kannst zwar gerät in unterschiedliches subnetz packen
aber dann kannst du immer noch an dem gerät hingehen und deine netzwerkeinstellungen ändern wenn
du denn rechte dafür hast und dich in ein anderes subnetz packen wenn du die geräte in unterschiedliche
wlans packst dann kannst du an dem client so viel ändern wie du lustig bist und der wird nicht auf
einmal andere rechner erreichen können also wenn du da auf nummer sichern gehen willst dass die
rechner auch wirklich nur miteinander quasi kommunizieren können oder das besser regeln
willst dann musst du sein eigenes wlans packen da kommst mit subnetz allein nicht weiter also du
verlässt dich darauf dass die leute keine rechte haben na gut so also wie war jetzt wie war jetzt die
ich war wlans auf beschreiben sie wie die pakete im ethernet hätte gekennzeichnet wenn gut
wlans tech ist im ethernet hätte irgendwo relativ weit vorne da gibt's glaube ich nen byte oder so
nen byte für wlans techs ich glaube es ist ein byte oder nee mehr vier byte wie viel zwei byte
zwei byte sind es zwei byte das könnt ihr doch nicht erwarten dass das jemand aus dem kopf
weiß wie viel byte im header dafür reserviert sind achso aus 12 bits ja aber ich glaube es
gibt noch irgendwelche zusatzdinger ich glaube es sind zwei byte es gibt nen wlans tech warum
warum beantworten die das da sich sich unten drunter aus selbst noch mal schönes bild dafür
ja hier das ist ein gutes bild tech vier bytes sind sogar ich habe nichts gesagt vier bytes sind
sogar hast schon vx laden gehört sagt mir nix ne sind sogar vier bytes das wusste ich gar nicht
na gut ja hier hier kannst du dein wlans tech reinschreiben
so und was 12 bits ja gut da muss wahrscheinlich 2 hoch 12 rechnen oder so 2 hoch 12
und dann wahrscheinlich eins abziehen weil null nicht gültig ist das weiß ich aber aus dem kopf
wirklich jetzt nicht also meistens geht es bis 4096 also ich glaube mehr als 4096 habe ich
noch nicht gesehen wobei theoretisch glaube ich auch mehr gehen müssten was ist denn denn 2 hoch
12 ane ok es geht nicht mehr 4096 wobei es 4095 sind wobei es 4095 sind weil ich glaube null
gilt nicht so der tech identify ane ein kollege möchte gerne ein kollege möchte gerne von zu
hause aus zugriff auf die station sind es 4095 würde fast sagen sind 4000 max vlan id
4095 sind reserviert ok dass null reserviert ist habe ich mir gedacht 4095 wusste ich nicht
ein kollege möchte gerne von zu hause aus auf die station zugriff auf die station bekommen
erläutern sie das konzept vpn gehen sie dabei auch auf die beteiligten komponenten sicherheitsaspekte
ein eurer chat chat das überlasse ich euch über vpn habe ich mich vorhin schon ausgelassen ich
will das jetzt nicht ihk konform beantworten müssen zumal die ihk sich ja selbst oftmals
nicht ganz einig ist was man eigentlich da antworten soll i fat time ja aber das klingt
auch alles nach machbar also hätte ich die prüfung geschrieben hätte ich höchstwahrscheinlich zum
damaligen zeitpunkt gewusst dass auch die letzte vlan all die reserviert ist und der rest ist ja
eigentlich gar nicht so schwer also also das einzige wo man wirklich wissen muss ist das hier also
man wirklich was auswendig gelernt haben muss ist eigentlich das hier dass die letzte all die
auch reserviert ist das hätte ich nicht gewusst aber das chat das kriegt ihr schon hin bin da
zuversichtlich doch 5 fat extrem hier angesagt guck mal wie viele IQ punkte ihr schon bekommen
habt nur die durch die ganzen prime subs ihr könnt eigentlich gar nicht durchfallen bei
der prüfung hier ist noch nie einer durchgefallen bei der prüfung
so ja ich glaube jetzt habe ich den chat alles beantwortet
leute mir ist was aufgefallen heute nacht ich habe es ja schon auf gestern gestern ich habe
sie auf twitter gepostet mein youtube premium ist ausgelaufen und ich musste jetzt nachts also
ich gucke ja ich gucke immer ich habe gerne ein bisschen ein bisschen sei es irgendwelche
musik sachen oder irgendwelche dokus oder sonst was ich habe ja gerne nachts ein bisschen youtube
laufen oder pen auf mal sein wenn youtube läuft und mein youtube premium ist ausgelaufen mir ist
aufgefallen wie unbenutzbar youtube auf mobile geräten ist also in dem fall auf dem iphone bei
mir ohne youtube premium du kannst es komplett vergessen und anscheinend sehen das noch mehr
leute so du kannst es komplett vergessen also youtube premium ist es geht ja gar nicht ohne du
hast vor jedem video mittlerweile eigentlich zwei werbespots die mit pech und nicht überspringen
sind du hast mit roll und du hast post roll also es ist komplett für den arsch ist komplett für
als ich habe gesagt ios leute ihr empfehlt mir irgendwelche android anwendungen da kann ich
nichts mit anfangen ich habe ein iphone da gibt es kein jupiter und auch kein wenz auf
meinem er auf meine android dingern habe ich damit auch nicht das problem aber auf meinem iphone
da geht das nicht so einfach aber wisst ihr was meine was meine lösungen dafür ist so wie ich
das eigentlich jetzt auch schon das letzte jahr über mache ich kaufe mir youtube premium in
indien youtube premium in indien kostet glaube ich monatlich 129 indische rupien das sind 1 euro 48
im monat das kann man sich leisten 1,50 im monat billiger als ein twitch prime sub
kann es sein dass ios 14 eine sicherheitslücke hat es hat so gut wie alles sicherheitslücken
ja und das kann man machen ich habe übrigens eine neue variante rausgefunden wie das noch
besser geht also ja man kann einfach einen vpn nehmen oder opera vpn oder sonst was aber ich
mache das ja immer über eine linux vm die ich mir bei digital ocean hole weil digital ocean
hat ein indisches rechenzentrum in bengalore
da ist noch bengut drinnen gehostet und über die vm schließe ich das aber dann immer ab
youtube premium bringt keine werbung und theoretisch den zugriff auf youtube exclusive sachen aber wer
will den scheiß gucken und du kannst videos herunterladen adblock unter ios nicht auf dem
desktop ist kein problem so und ich habe jetzt noch was besseres festgestellt das zeige ich
euch aber in einem der nächsten streams glaube ich mal das ist jetzt total einfach bisher habe
ich mir in indien eine vm gemietet habe darüber einen browser x vorwortet und habe mich dann
eingeloggt jetzt habe ich rausgekriegt es ist total einfach man kann mit ssh mit einem
kommandos und socks proxy aufmachen dann stellt man dann so sein lokalen firefox auf den socks
proxy um und schon geht alles über indien easy sache von zwei minuten aber richtig richtig
pains champion hat dns auswirkung aus gaming und routing die frage ist jetzt sehr allgemein
gestellt also streng genommen nicht aber je nachdem wie breit man diese frage auslegt
kann man da sich schon was zurecht legen dass das auswirkung also da muss jetzt da muss jetzt
ein bisschen aus und also aufs routing direkt hat dns natürlich keine auswirkung aber je
nachdem welchen dns server du nimmst ist es theoretisch möglich dass die anfragen anders
aufgelöst werden aber nur theoretisch in der regel gibt natürlich jeder dns aber die
gleiche ip mal von anycast aus von anycast abgesehen aber theoretisch könnte es natürlich
so sein dass der telekom dns deine anfrage auf die telekom suchmaschine umleitet weil
sie sich denkt hey das muss auch mal wieder sein und keine ahnung cloud flair und google
nicht oder was auch immer also dns hat höchstens auswirkung darauf wenn es halt nicht so auflöst
wie du aufgelöst haben willst wo du hin musst und dann dass irgendwie ins leere läuft also
dns direkte auswirkung aus routing nee hat damit nichts zu tun und aufs gaming eigentlich
auch gar nicht solange die auflösung halt geht weil es wird ja nicht für jedes paket
eine neue dns abfrage gemacht es wird einmal eine dns abfrage gemacht wenn man dort überhaupt
auf ip wenn man dort überhaupt auf dns namen geht und nicht direkt auf irgendwelche ips
die man über irgendeinen zentralen server ausgetauscht hat aber das wird einmalig aufgelöst
und dann wird das quasi so gut wie nie auf neu aufgelöst das wird erstmal gecasht und
dann ist gut also dns hat eigentlich keine auswirkung solange es funktioniert weil dann
funktioniert also wenn dns nicht funktioniert wird auch gaming nicht funktionieren weil
du dann dich beispielsweise bei steam gar nicht einloggen kannst aber wenn dns an sich
funktioniert dann hat es keine auswirkung auf gaming und routing auch wenn es ein bisschen
langsamer ist von also du kriegst jetzt keinen geschwindigkeits boost dadurch dass du einen
anderen dns vielleicht einträgst der eine millisekunde schneller antwortet oder so
über irgendwelche random proxies im internet würde ich aber mich nicht einloggen bei google
und passwörter und kreditkarten und sowas eingeben klar das geht alles immer noch über
tls also hat tps aber irgendwie wieder strebt mir den gedanke trotzdem wozu braucht man
diese nord vpn geschichten eigentlich gar nicht der einzige fall ist leute die illegal
irgendwelche torrens scheren wollen oder der einzig sinnvolle fall der mir so einfällt
ist man möchte geo sperren wie bei netflix oder so umgehen was ist denn eine double stack
ip du meinst eine dual stack du meinst dual stack gehe ich mal von aus nicht double stack
dual stack damit ist gemeint dass wenn du einen dual stack hast dass du eine ipv4 und
eine ipv6 ip bekommst das eigentliche problem um was es hier wahrscheinlich geht ist nicht
dual stack sondern dual stack lite bei dual stack lite bekommst du keine ipv4 adresse
mehr sondern nur ipv6 und dein ipv4 traffic wird über ipv6 getunnelt deswegen hat man
da probleme mit also es ist wahrscheinlich also erstens mal ist es dual stack und zweitens
ist das problem wahrscheinlich nicht dual stack sondern dual stack lite sagt man mal
bei vodafone unity media ein notizblock ja das passiert auf provider seite es wird ipv4
wird über ipv6 getunnelt und auf der provider seite scherst du dir dann eine ausgangs ip
mit mehreren kunden und dieser ausgangspunkt nennt sich bei vodafone übrigens aftergate
way so
damit glaube ich sieht man das irgendwo ich weiß gar nicht was meine tägliche oder insgesamt
youtube nutzungen ist aber wie machst du das dann mit deinem indischen indischen youtube
premium ich mache mir eine vm in indien also das würde ich jetzt nicht jedem empfehlen
da ist vpn wahrscheinlich einfacher ich mache mir eine vm in indien in bengalore im rechenzentrum
mit digital ocean und dann tunnel ich über diese vm meinen traffic um dort zu bezahlen
ssh minus n minus d 8000 ip adresse vom server und dann lokal den browser proxy umstellen
auf den port 8000 und dann bis in indien ich kann euch mal zeigen in einem der nächsten
streams ist total einfach kostet aber fünf cent oder so für die vm ihr könnt auch vpn
verwenden also ich habe das glückbar vodafone weil ich lange noch genervt habe und ich anscheinend
auch den service eines irgendwie vp betreuer oder so mal genießen durfte wahrscheinlich
habe ich oft genug öffentlichkeitswirksam auf twitter rum geflämt oder ich weiß ich
ob das wie ip betreuer war aber es war schon sehr auffällig habe ich einen richtig echten
dual stack mit ipv4 und ipv6 ich habe so oft auf twitter rum geflämt und irgendwann also
der support hat sich die ganze zeit übelst rum geht rum gedrückt so wollen nicht und
können nicht und hier und da und das geht nicht oder habe ich so da habe ich ja mal
wirklich als wir probleme haben im ziel ich habe ja vier tage am stück quasi nur rum
geflämt auf twitter und da hat sich irgendwie einer mit mit komplett anderer sprechweise
bei mir gemeldet und hat gefragt selbstverständlich bieten wir die ja auch eine rückerstattung
an und so was für die ausfälle da habe ich auch gedacht ok was ist jetzt einmal los
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher das war nicht mehr der normale support das war irgendein
typ der für schadensbegrenzung da ist wenn die leute zu sehr auf glitter über vodafone
herziehen wann kam vodafone schon mal zu euch und hat gesagt ihr bekommt von sich aus ihr
bekommt eine gut schrift
wenn aktueller überlegen wie ich war ja gar vpn perkett das ist ganz einfach das ist
ganz einfach entweder direkt über ipv6 die mobilfunknetze haben mittlerweile ipv6 problematisch
ist halt nur wenn du an irgendeiner stelle wo du das vpn brauchst kein ipv6 hast also
wenn du komplett ipv6 machen kannst für vpn dann ist easy dann hast du gar kein problem
da brauchst du nämlich kein natt und du brauchst gar nichts geht einfach direkt von ipv6 vpn
auf ipv6 wenn du karrier great nutt hast und über ipv4 machen willst dann ist die
einfachste variant an den tunnel zu bauen über irgendeine externe ip im internet du
mietest dir zum beispiel irgendeine ausrufe zeichen hetzner by the way im chat du mietest
dir zum beispiel einen günstigen server in der hetzner cloud kannst du jetzt zum beispiel
machen mit meinem 20 euro startguthaben gutschein den ihr euch sichern könnt wenn du euch jetzt
registriert bei hetzner und meinen code einlöst bekommt ihr bis ende des jahres oder einlösen
könnt es bis ende des jahres bekommt ihr einen 20 euro startguthaben bonus auf eurer cloud
konto so da kannst du hier eine billige vm holen zum beispiel lida da bekommst du eine
ipv4 adresse dabei hallo hetzner please da bekommst du eine ipv4 adresse dabei und dann
tunnelst du dich da drüber das einfachste dürfte ein ssh tunnel sein ssh tunnel und
dann da drüber ports weiterleiten auf dein vpn also du würdest dann ssh also mit ssh
tunnel ist es halt am einfachsten du würdest den ssh tunnel machen intern auf deine hetzner
cloud vm und darüber dann quasi port weiterleiten an deinen vpn also hier drüber das dürfte
am einfach du kriegst das sicherlich wenn du guckst auch noch billiger irgendwo aber
hetzner hat halt den vorteil die haben ganz gute anbindung und locations verteilt in deutschland
und finland falls du noch finland wahrscheinlich eher nicht traffic ist eigentlich kein thema
und du kannst dich auch was verfügbarkeit und anbindung und geschwindigkeit nicht beschweren
also da hast du keine probleme da bist du auf jeden fall auf der sicheren seite wenn
du es hier bei hetzner machst gibt auch zig andere anbieter aber ich habe mittlerweile
alles bei hetzner
so wie auch immer das gemeint ist kann es so ja nicht funktionieren weil du musst immer
noch von außen an deinen vpn erst mal dran kommen einfach alles exponieren das geht ja
auch nicht du kannst ja nicht alles exponieren mit carrier crate nut es sei denn eins und
eins lässt sich auf ihren routern einloggen was ich mal bezweifle als ja mal anfragen
nenne ich eins und eins vodafone habe ich hier noch für ein video auf ambi leitstelz
jetzt wird jetzt eigentlich gucken leute ich sehe gerade urzeit was ist denn hier schon
wieder los kann es sein dass wir zwei stunden einfach nur sinnlos geschwätzt haben ohne
irgendwas auch noch anzugucken ich wollte mich eigentlich noch rasieren ich wollte
duschen gehen ich wollte noch rasieren muss man hier früh alles machen
der brezl snacker ist auch wieder da soll ich schau mal kurz ob es irgendjemand gibt
dem haus so ankönnen
by the way ich muss auch mal kurz new world flame weil wir gerade dabei sind steams der
als letztes wochenende new world cacuate wir sind jetzt genau wir sind jetzt genau 400.000
spieler down also wie gesagt ich gebe der sache bis februar dann ist vorbei magst du
kurz was erzählen zu zfs und bunto procken ja es gibt einen bug wenn du upgrade ist zfs
technisch und das ist ganz böser bug weil der wohl silent dein fall ist im corrupted
den zfs hast du upgraded ja den können wir denn hosten jetzt haben wir irgendjemand hier
samper video an den haben wir schon so oft gehostet ist keiner da dem ich folge von den
kleinen der irgendwas gerade macht was ich spannend finde egal leute wir gehen jetzt
ich gehe jetzt auf bis denn machts gut bis denn zu